خلف قضبان سجن افين سيء السمعه اسرار
مخيفه تحدث عنها سجناء سابقون ومنظمات
حقوقيه تعذيب ممنهج وبترو للاطراف واعتداء
على سجينات هذه القصص سنكشفها في هذه
المهمه الخاصه مع الناجين من السجن والذين
فروا الى كندا
[موسيقى]
عندما كنا في الزنزانه كنا نحو 116 سجلا
في غرفه حجمها سته امتار في سته وهناك
حمامات او ثلاثه للاستحمام واستخدام
المرافق الصحيه والوضوء ويجب على كل شخص
ان يستخدمها لمده لا تتعدى العشر دقائق
والا
وعندما جاء احد الحراس وسال من يهتم ويدير
هذه الغرفه قلت له انا فجلدني خمسه وسبعين
جلده بسبب تاخر بعض السجناء في استخدام
الحمامات
[موسيقى]
كنت احد الناجين من سجن افين حيث تم
الافراج عنك قبل باسابيع قليله قبل حدوث
مجزره عام 1988 هل تعتبر نفسك من
المحظوظين لانه افرج عنك قبل هذه المجزره
وتكون واحد من الضحايا ابدا لن اقول انا
محظوظ بانني لم اكن جيدا مثل بقيه
المعدومين اعتقد انني لم اكن صالحا مثلهم
[موسيقى]
الشخص الذي كان معي كان صادقا جدا لكن انا
لم اكن مثلهم
انا
عندما اعتقلوا بقينا لمده اربعه او خمسه
اشهر والدتي لم تعلم اين هو وبعد سته اشهر
سمحوا لها بمعرفه انه معتقلون لديهم لكنهم
قالوا انهم لا يعلمون لماذا اعتقل والى
متى سيبقى في السجن
والدتي توفيت في عمر التاسعه والاربعين
عاما بجلطه قلبيه لانها لم تتحمل الوضع